the Joe Rogan experience I feel bad for
people that are working at places where
they're exposed to this disease and get
nothing for it so that's what I said
earlier like if you're working a grocery
store and it's like you're getting [ __ ]
money and you're being exposed to this
it's like we should do as a country we
should do something for you
yeah I don't know what it is maybe it's
like hey man you know student loan we're
taking care of it or like hey you want a
good interest rate on a mortgage five
years from now we're doing it for you
like we got to do something for those
people right cuz if your job used to be
stacking apples now your job is you
could die stacking up stacking apples
some weight because we're all depending
on those supply chains and those things
being open yeah so if you're putting
meat in the package if you were in
Bristol Farms the store that I love if
you're doing whatever so your spot
that's my spot I love it it's just great
it's just it's it's for new money it's
for trash it's not like irawan which is
for healthy people Bristol Farms is for
millionaires at one Apple Jacks it's
like you know it's like four you know
yeah tick-tock people rappers I saw a
lady in air one she was dressed up like
a hot beekeeper yeah that's what yeah
she was so protective goggles and the
man Bristol Farms is like absurd it's
like people pull up in Bentley's and
gets s'mores pie they have s'mores pie
at Bristol farm it's like you gotta be a
little gutter trash you know but it's
those people need some benefit so that's
what I mean when I say it's a failure
the government it's not like it's not
you can't pin it directly on Trump
everyone pins everything directly on
Trump I don't think he's doing
phenomenally especially in communicating
he's doing what he does but I think they
look at the system and you go well we
just passed a two trillion dollar
bailout with giving people $1,200 that
can't be the solution well anything he
does that's really good
gets minimized when he does something
stupid yeah it's hard for people to give
him like that there's no good guy about
his rating yeah the popos rating yeah
bachelor yeah that's not trolling if
that's not trolling then I don't know
it's you can't do that when people are
falling down dead it's crazy you can't
do it it was anything good that he does
like right closing off traffic to China
early you
yeah and in deciding yeah hey listen
this travel that China is not smart back
and forth we have to stop that and
people are really upset at him that gets
diminished by a tweet like I think he
wants people to like I think he wants
the media in Hollywood the like I think
that's what his supporters don't
understand I think he actually is a
creation of Hollywood all these people
that are like Hollywood Trump's taking
on Hollywood it's like he's a creation
of Hollywood this is the guy that loved
the Clintons up until he ran against
them well he was so it's just convenient
that he became this crusader against the
elites that he spent his entire life
around well that was his point was yeah
I know what they actually do cuz I used
to paint them a hundred percent I mean
that was a point that people bought into
it they're like oh yeah this guy's gonna
fight on our behalf I've just never
believed that about any politicians I'm
an adult I think it's complicated like
every yeah you know you almost die like
him sure you today yes show yeah that a
guy like him can get through sure you
understand the frailty of the system yes
he'll exploit yeah yeah hackers to like
test you you're yes you can get through
Oregon they give a guy a gun at the
airport and all can you get through yeah
right but I mean hackers it's a famous
thing that companies will do the hire
hackers to try to break into their
software yeah to find out as you know
what our what our vulnerability it's
just this is a weird this is a weird
thing to run a simulation this is a
weird during a pandemic it might not be
the idea to run a simulation with a guy
be like hey let's see I don't think it's
a simulation no I'm not I'm this guy
yeah the exploit but now we know the
exploit look having a popularity contest
to see who controls the nukes is crazy
it's crazy especially because we're
frivolous yeah what do we pay more
attention to the Kardashians who's right
today and I gotta be honest with you
they won't like if Kim Kardashian would
make a better president than a lot of
people a lot of people in Congress and
that's how that's how crazy it's gotten
that's so crazy
that she's not the worst not there she's
not the worst she's not the worst she's
not the worst she's a businesswoman no
she's smart she's working for prison
reform she's doing things she goes to
trump yeah helps people get out of jail
that are unjustly imprisoned she has for
many many people right now that's pretty
like more than 18 people have been
released because of Kim Kardashian I
think it's crazy Kim I'll go with you if
you want to go to the White House I love
you I'll take what I want to see you
with a maggot hat on I will go there I'm
gonna say well yeah we're anyhow do you
think that would ruin your Hollywood
career I don't think if I if I have a
Hollywood career someone let me know
someone email me or call if I have a
Hollywood career I don't want yeah my
crews in my in my apartment that's
better I mean that's the reality my
careers in microphone I get to see what
I want yeah
I would like to Jaime die I'd like to be
an extra in Curb Your Enthusiasm or
something I could do some very funny on
a show like that
[Applause]